da gekommen schätzt
schweiz zustande der verkauf steht
[Gelächter]
sonst könnte die kooperation frauen
luise schneider steht am ende ihres
lebens doch jeden tag ist sie so
unterwegs als stünde alles noch vor
was treibt die 83 jährige an woher nimmt
die renterin die kraft für ihren kampf
gegen waffen und gebaut
stelle
wir haben dann muss ich wohl auch
wechsel schnell und ist august nicht
schaffen
[Musik]
ja
werden vor einem halben jahr den
spätherbst die gruppe für eine schweiz
ohne armee hat gemeinsam mit einem links
grünen bündnis das referendum gegen den
kampfflieger klippen ergriffen
50.000 unterschriften müssen nun
gesammelt werden muss so kann das volk
über das flugzeug entscheiden
luisa ist an vorderster front dabei
einmal auf wird sie der seite stehen
das möchte sie noch erleben darf es
nicht langsam zeit also komisch das auto
spielt seit es die gruppe für eine
schweiz ohne armee gibt ist luisa mit
dabei die geheimwaffe der chor
gewissermaßen
mehrere hundert unterschriften kommen an
diesem tag zusammen was ich jetzt schon
abzeichnet das referendum wert zustande
kommen
[Musik]
wochen später bei luise schneider zu
hause sie wohnt am stadtrand von bern an
bester lage
hier lebt sie mit ihrem mann paul er ist
92 jahre alt noch immer liegen die
beiden den riesigen garten selber mit
ausdauer was man brauchen
unten im keller ist das reich von paul
hier hat der ehemalige technische
angestellte seine werkstatt
mit ein grund weshalb sie immer noch
hier wohnen
paul kann sich noch nicht kennen von all
seinen dingen das ist für ein leben lang
hatte alles selber geblickt rund ums
haus jetzt ist fast nichts mehr möglich
paul hat parkinson
[Musik]
nein
seit pauls krankheit ist das
zusammenleben schwieriger geworden paul
möchte immer noch unabhängig sein
luisa hingegen hat angst davor dass er
sich verletzt noch sei es dazu aber
nicht an der zeit sagt mir luise ich
frage mich wie lange die beiden hier
noch bleiben können
der anruf
[Applaus]
und vita des luise unterwegs
solidaritätslauf für song papier eine
runde will sie zu fuß gehen
symbolisch näher liege in ihrem alter
nicht mehr drin
[Musik]
nicht nur kämpfen gegen waffen auch
einstehen für diejenigen am rande der
gesellschaft das sei ihre friedensarbeit
erklärt sinniert
[Applaus]
[Musik]
50 franken holt louise mit dieser einen
runde für die snp ag
und mir fällt auf wie sehr sie es
genießt inmitten der leute zu sein
[Musik]
offene kirche heilig geist im zentrum
der stadt bern louise will dass ich
dorthin mit komme wo sie ein capped wenn
ihr danach zumute ist
jetzt fehlen sollte je nach kraft wo man
einfach dass ich hier wo es gerade nach
und hier merke ich woraus schöpft in
ihrem leben mit frömmigkeit habe sie
aber nichts am hut belehrt ziemlich
gleich sie fühle sich als teil eines
großen ganzen eine ordnung und das
glaube sie und da habe sie den auftrag
zum frieden zur gerechtigkeit
die ausbeute die sich absolut wort
missbrauch programm christentum hat -
und geben das kühle wasser predigen
[Musik]
wieder daheim mittlerweile ist klar das
volk wird in drei monaten über den kampf
briten entscheiden können
[Musik]
luise und paul bei ihrem lieblings spiel
skrupel ein fester bestandteil im
tagesablauf
[Gelächter]
seit 60 jahren sind die beiden
verheiratet drei kinder haben sie groß
gezogen
[Musik]
auf dem zweiten bildungsweg lernte luisa
sozialarbeiterin
politisch war sie immer aktiv
aufgewachsen als arbeiterkinder namen
verhältnissen sei sie von ihren eltern
geprägt worden
vor allem vom vater einem gewerkschafter
und pazifisten mit aller kraft für den
frieden so hätten sie gelebt
luise vorne paul im hintergrund die wir
bewusst das ist aber sicher die zeit
geht es besser das ist verdient
unbewilligte demonstration auf dem
bundesplatz eine spontanaktion es ist
der tag an dem der nationalrat das
gesetz für die waffenausfuhren locker
die aktivisten der chor den wimpel
[Musik]
die bösen aus ihrer sicht werden
ausgebuht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kontaktperson spieler ja der kandidat
muss personen arbeiten wird das stimmt
oder man muss man ändern
[Musik]
während die einen ihr fett abkriegen
schaden sich die prominenten
gesinnungsgenossen um luise
so entsteht ein tag ist das nicht das
ist bitter
[Musik]
welche ideen erhöht dass ich morgens
mitgefahren zu profitieren muss man das
auch stark
[Musik]
im sekretariat der regionalgruppe der
zwei monate vor der abstimmung zum
gerieten spendenbriefe werden abgepackt
um den abstimmungskampf zu finanzieren
junge aktivisten kommen und gehen in
dieser basisdemokratischen organisation
luise bleibt für mich ganz konkret
kommen hier möglich machen
die arbeiten verlaufen
die offensive politik was ich versteh
greif ist damit genommen
die aktivisten treffen sich einmal pro
monat
tradition hat das luisa denz objekt
sonderwünsche inbegriffen
dafür die verordnung seit über 30 jahren
haben die leute dieser gruppierung ein
großes ziel die armee abzuschaffen so
annehme bruch der aussieht als ich ende
die gruppe bis bewegt bewegung bringt
und so verschiedene letzte chance ist
vier mal krachen und ich habe
mittlerweile begriffen unser all diesen
jungen leuten ist luise daheim machen
er will dass die verantwortlichkeiten
für die reagieren die jungen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ja
das uhr los kind ronja ist zu besuch zu
bekommen enkelin olivia und freundinnen
aus der aktivisten szene generation der
ikk-direkt doch kochen und dann kommt
wieder die frage noch ein paar tage dann
wissen sie ob sie zu den gewinnern
gehören aber dem zentrum der diskussion
steht für einmal nicht die politik
sondern die nächste generation
[Musik]
dass man jetzt noch genauso und dann ist
er da der tag der entscheidungen
die gegner des kampfjets griffen
formieren sich in einer beiz zum
abstimmungs event luisa ist mittendrin
klar ist es wird knapp werden
doch alles deutet darauf hin dass es
heute zum ersten mal klappen könnte mit
einem sieg
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ein historischer tag für luise
[Applaus]
ihr jahrelanger kampf wird belohnt
das volk lehnt an der urne den kampfjet
gerieten
[Applaus]
das sorgte soße die gäste
[Musik]
dann nach dem ersten jubel sofort die
nachricht anbau der daheim geblieben ist
[Musik]
und ich bin mir sicher
trotz dieses erfolgs heute luisa wird
nicht ruhen
sie wird weitermachen solange sie kam es
ist ihr auftrag
nein
[Musik]